So,we made some changes in the browser itself.
>> But we can't share those changes.
>> Right or save them.
>> Right so to do that I guess we're going to have
to be a little more sophisticated than just working the browser. We're
going to need to get a code editor and we need to
get the code and how are we going to get the code?
>> So, the code is stored on GitHub so we will need GitHub accounts
and we'll need to actually figure out how to get the code from GitHub.
>> And you, depending on your background in programming you may already have a
code you may like, you may know nothing about GitHub or you may be
an expert, so answer this next question it'll sort of guide you, there might
be some videos that you can skip and we don't want to waste anyone's time.